hey what's up i'm jake i'm here with
Alex new house and we are about to play
a game called snow horse oh boy uh this
game looks bad boy how do you duh
basically we were like we should
probably do a gamespot place today so
we're looking through steam to see what
we could find and turns out this little
gem just recently came out called snow
horse so uh let's give it a shot dude
take a moment to appreciate these fat
beats ya allah no man ok that's right
yeah this game this game looks great
it's apparently made by a programmer at
unity econ just made it in this free
time looks stellar let's check it out so
yeah we got here this sweet menu with a
with a rainbow customized option will
check that out later probably let's just
jump right into and see what's up with
snow horse I mean so yeah that didn't
work with the gamepad you have to use
dancing committed so we we got to go big
air right right off the bat sure let's
do it figure snowboards don't care were
you into all right oh man yeah so snores
is neither of us has played this before
so we're gonna check this out i don't
know what's happening I don't know how
out of his tape oh and he's on a piece
on my yeah you've landed that haha how
did you land that I can't that was it
what also I can't I have to use the
mouse on this uh yeah right do do that
again I was so that that's all it is
just big ass also I can't change the
camera so this is about what you're
getting you can't move horizontally
either it's just like [ __ ] but I can do
these sick tricks what that didn't even
make any sense yeah but look at that
sick horse
okay I've had about enough of this level
all right where's mouse there we go uh
yeah let's try what are this okay North
Slope maybe this will be more
interesting probably not though yeah i
mean but look at those look at those
mountains look at that swiss village
mountain village oh man I still don't
understand like the design behind the
blue thing come out of his tail are you
going back I'm going Packers oh man me
oh let's see this in this sick oh no
nice ragdoll physics on their horse here
yeah I don't oh this is just supposed to
be like tracking where you go this green
thing coming out of but I don't underst
what does it say I'm an old horse poop
screen what does it say on it's a on the
snowboard I think it's like recyclable
that's my guy I see the recyclable sign
and you're on a piece of cardboard I
wonder if you can get different boards
oh we should check out the custom wonder
if you can get different mounts for the
mount oh man that would do some met
amount oh man ah I want to I'm trying to
do I think you can do different tricks
because I was just spinning but maybe
not gonna do wow this oh man yeah the
jump button totally responds it was red
shred the movie shred some pow-pow yeah
dude how many nor points do you have
eight it's a lot in our points all right
this didn't even make any sense uh-uh
horse loves tacos yeah you loves tacos
so much they decided not only in that
even though it was sick this makes me
wanna watch Bojack horseman yeah oh man
I can just spin yeah but I use the music
is the best part of the game the beats
also all right let's see Ryan get up
there oh right
oh man but look at this look at those
spins I got going hey I can see my house
from here yeah no I can't it's right to
your left that one all right horse house
there you go that's your house right yep
uh yeah this game man it's something
also I love how there's like there's
just floating platforms like there's no
explanation just oh alright what oh that
was great uh we need to customize this I
think we need it okay is it but then we
should do the UH here we go this oh boy
it's the this is men we're getting into
some real depth here game play depth all
right uh what wait hold on you're not
gonna check out the top hat uh I mean oh
man that's it yep yep we got it wait oh
yeah that's pretty good yes uh oh man if
it I can't believe is not backwards um
trying to try the bandana okay in the
bunny ears the bandanas did that horse
looks like no no this is something I
think we got a good thing about that
right top head of the pumpkin pumpkin
just looks on wieldy hey I the top ads
not bet you cannot snowboard with
pumpkin on your head no it's just not
aerodynamic oh here we go sick boards uh
I mean we can't be you know forward and
shred the gnar on any more cardboard on
a gamespot snowboard I know we haven't
which one
what's iLike the one with the rainbow
that's not really complete in the horse
over it do that one yeah that one's
pretty cool and then what's oh the last
things your tail okay yeah let's change
okay colors choose Brown so it does look
like horse [ __ ] okay yep there we go oh
man look at that that's like ms paint
level detail there ok let's try
avalanche right okay all right let's see
what let's see what's up here avalanche
it's great that there's more stages
coming soon because like I mean then I
just need more of them I'd more yeah I
need all the stages I mean you gotta
hand it to the developer they're really
supporting this with some extra comp
extra content coming soon some sweet DLC
drops come in a snow horse all right
let's you this is lips with like no way
at all this is this is what I was just
playing no I don't think so no this is
different I feel like do you get points
for go all right okay snow horse needs
love ya there's got high it's got to be
some way to do tricks right i mean i
just do i do tricks on you yeah just
lots of horse spinners yeah oh man
that's sweet backwards flip I'm sorry's
you don't get points for going backwards
but yeah you should you really should
and so I guess things are a little
different is it is a snow horse and the
universe of any expanded universe is no
more so you can do tricks but I'm this
and the core and the core cannon yeah
you gonna write a book yeah I prefer
rights no horse benfica say guys coming
soon to gamespot com snow horse
fanfiction and confirm it here so oh god
oh no that was a mess um I'm curious
where the avalanches isn't this one
called avalanche yet there is no
avalanche I'll have to get through the
whole thing I
screwed up that one mega so all right
with oh man low altitude flipping I know
like not even going that fast like you
can just no words Saturday's hey now
yeah but look look at this talk like the
top at seriously makes the same way
three times better so from a1 to a3 yeah
so I guess that's why you can't go up
hills sideways yeah all right um I'm in
the horse poop just at launch street I
do like the nice detailed animation of
the horse just slowly trotting the place
on the snowboard how many horsepower it
is this a no one I me with the top out
there all right okay that didn't make
any sense I want to get through this
level but I don't like it seems like
it's conspiring against us
alright let's see this is the this is a
good run through guys we're gonna make
it here i'm really curious about the
music me too like I don't know we should
watch the credits I bet they're like 10
seconds long so I don't think it would
take too much time she like who did this
music if it's like a friend of this guy
or he just like fitted himself cuz if he
did it himself then I'm kind of like
nice sweet kind of inclined to think
that he just made this game so he could
put his music and yeah yeah I mean each
of the song credits that come up like
you know they have different artists all
I know what sounds like that different
artists oh you're not gonna okay all
right also on this level I can't control
myself on the ground so oh nice let's oh
it's just like don't mess this up nice
know that I'm nicing myself by the way
this has to be the end nice got this
nice detail to the tree right there I
want to see if there's a if they're
right nope that's so these are the
options you got sound no sound no sound
until you say you know what I played so
much snow horse I think it's time to
start over yeah there's no credits
either so unless we have to be all of
the levels and we've already beaten
three yeah all right let's let's do
bunny hill just see because you know
yeah we went hard but now we got to go
less hard maybe snow horse needs a break
oh so there are tricks if you play on
keyboard interesting I'm gonna have to
switch the keyboard we've been playing
on gamepad yogi what you get for being a
being a scrub yeah I know I'm a console
scrub what groans are you thinking okay
oh god oh no this is even better to do
any yeah all right but you can just hit
you can just hit him like crazy yeah oh
sweet
all right hold on I'm gonna I'm gonna
redo that level with using the keyboard
all right so we get for not starting
with it tutorial level big air let's do
some bigger I forgot what is it yeah
oh yeah that's it
I think he just broke his legs yeah yeah
buddy like sweet candy so it's okay you
can got fixes broken legs I don't I mean
he's a horse yeah when a horse breaks is
likes you shoot up don't you what is
happening I don't think you can make it
to the down part you just you just break
your legs yeah that's also i'm gaining
points by doing nothing I know oh oh
sweet so you can gain points before you
start just by holding down to spin
buttons oh gosh so look watch this
alright so I'm just holding on the send
button right now yeah but he's got style
so it's okay to do tricks on the ground
oh god that's good in so you can't lane
anything no because it flips you
sideways then you can't read like right
yourself because maybe amazing i started
spinning before the game starts this
trip make a good point hit button yeah
there you go oh man all right this is go
get harder to land when you start
spamming buns I guess so I don't think
snow horse makes much logical sense I
don't think they're going for logic here
you know hey alright so i must get
harder because i'm gonna all right i
also also I guess you go faster if you
hold down forward oh god oh my gosh this
is a train wreck not the game I playing
of the game is that clearly dings and I
could have sworn that name that just
came up for this song with Lindsey luck
yeah I think it might well have to go to
the tape sweet all right are you like
not jumping before like I mean I'm
trying I'm gonna have to try this you're
not even making it yeah that's right all
right what
sweet did you know the chance to jump
there all right we're gonna have to
comply out to finish this level this is
insane I can't finish the snow level
guys right it's like the easiest one to
you don't even do anything did I make it
do they make it do tricks now sweet all
right Wow zero points I know I got
fourth 47 tennis points I don't know why
all right it doesn't have a restart
button either so you know we're gonna
have to UM mouth yeah it's maddeningly
when you haven't done right yeah oh it's
night outside this could change the
entire game also I like this a play on
the state looking dishes nice nice pond
there right okay it's nighttime we're
getting crazy a bit I feel like the
audio is like delayed too yeah I don't
actually know it sounds okay it's just
weird like this always makes sense do
some tricks bro oh yeah you know you're
just gonna eat it because if you do lots
of tricks yeah you didn't know that what
ok so it's stacks but it doesn't it
doesn't say this you have to land
perfect yeah but i feel like if you spam
it enough it's gonna be impossible
lamper yeah because i think so i think
if the more you press like it'll just
keep doing those over the overtime so
like it'll complete one and then just
move on to the next one that you pressed
I see so yeah so if I do like one then
it'll be fun or not ok I guess uh I
guess that one's just broken well yeah
but you know I still got the six pins
down hey slide
yeah it's one trick there we go we
landed a trick he remained another we
landed another trick oh you went a
little crazy there oh nice got it
Lindsey low end oh I get it that's
pretty good yes so he must be doing I
sex himself right oh alright that's
awkward yeah nice ok can't land like
that so we gotta get on the on the
leaderboards because this thing does
have full leaderboards you got out you
gotta at this rate we're not gonna get
on the leaderboards but i gotta delisted
oh nice alright alright alright here's
some lindsay lohan for you oh man i'm
just clearly just not good enough at
this game but at least the horses style
though
yeah yeah nice oh god oh god yeah so
Jake what's your opinion of snow horse
so far it looks like garbage um but I
I'm enjoying it though yes so like it's
got that fun factor I will never play
this again not that I played it at all
but like after this after this is over
I'll never think about this game will
never play it again but right now i'm
fairly entertained by this i like that i
like the flowers that come out it's nice
oh nice so since you played it though
people probably want to know your
opinion more than mine a straighter
they're just dying to know what you
think of this game especially as a
gamespot editor yes I should see if you
can review this game yeah knee-jerk
reaction 1 out of 10 plus 9 out of 10
for fun factor so this is a train wreck
what is amazing alright well we are
running at a time so let's see if you
can make this before time runs out
alright this is the this is for all the
marbles this is the this is the speed
run for ok perfect you can do it see if
we can get ourselves on the leaderboard
see we can beat IGN yeah I chins up
there we gotta beat them nope alright
alright one more try one more try ok
this is it it all comes down to this
one-shot you'll have beaten the game in
20 minutes if you beat this level ok if
not you fail in a snow horse doesn't
love you I should hand in my resignation
over snores just like put a pack on snow
horse write your resignation and then
just send it to the office yep oh god am
I gonna make it you're gonna hit the
cheese you cannot eat it well alright
one more time one works guy I mean to
say that this is definitely it was it
all right let's do this I'm hyper
focused right now my palms are sweaty
knees weak arms are heavy yeah his vomit
on his sweater already I mean so fun
diverse is nervous fun facts lose
yourself was actually written about snow
horse all before he was about to hit the
slopes you're gonna hit it again its own
no I got it Oh swinging all right got to
get that spin for style uh all right
don't ya okay keep it simple maybe maybe
pop one trick off here one there oh no
now you're good no you're not good no I
got it I got it cleared it okay I'm
leered it sweet oh this game is trash is
that a wall and it looks like a wall
this is almost it no all right we're
gonna get in and I better see on that
all right we're sweet that is no horse
thanks for thanks for playing Alex yeah
and if you want to buy this game i think
it's like five dollars on Steam right
now I wouldn't recommend it and less
like I don't know unless you want to
have get it get a few laughs but yeah
that's no horse thanks for watching
you